it's a great pleasure to be here I any
of you have been to Vegas recognize the
phenomenon of a warm-up act and that's
what I really am here today because the
main attraction follows it's
particularly pleasant for me to be in
the Harvard club I'm a Yale graduate and
in one of my frequent vacations from
public life I was the director of the
Institute of Politics at the Kennedy
School at Harvard where I advertise
myself as a one-man affirmative action
program being a Yale graduate and a
Republican who had held public offices
such showing up in the Harvard Yard you
know those of us who have been involved
in the cause of civil justice reformer
often met with a rejoinder that says you
know this is all very interesting but
it's of interest solely to lawyers and
judges and to academics we know
differently quite the contrary the cause
of tort reform is or should be of
concern to all Americans it should be a
concern to working men and women whose
jobs are threatened when employers have
to absorb higher costs of product
liability and securities litigation in
terms of damages and increased insurance
costs costs all costs that make them
less competitive particularly in
international markets where their
competitors don't have to deal with
these burdens it's important to the
average American because job losses and
sue when class-action bankruptcies such
as have occurred in the asbestosis and
breast implant situations occur and it's
important because of the higher medical
costs that are imposed across the board
due to defensive medicine and to
burgeoning malpractice insurance rates
up we need only be reminded with this
morning's news of a walkout at GE
because of this very factor in the
employment package they have their
toward reform is also important to the
rich American family they pay higher
prices generally across the board for
consumer goods that are subject to what
as accurately and fairly been described
as a tort tax the added costs due to
abusive litigation which goes into the
cost of the product and of course the
American family pays those higher
medical costs and in addition is subject
to the withdrawal of important medical
services in some areas such as we're
seeing right now in the state of West
Virginia and in my home state of
Pennsylvania where such a walkout by
doctors particularly ob/gyn doctors was
averted only by a last-minute band-aid
applied by the incoming governor another
cost that we all pay is the fact that
any of us who have litigation to pursue
find the courts often clogged with
lawsuits that are either frivolous or
questionable validity so we really see
this impact across the board around our
nation it builds on the phenomenon that
I would describe as a culture of
victimization where all of us seem to
quest for a totally risk-free Society
and whenever anything goes wrong the
first question often asked is a whom do
I sue well of course ready to answer
that question is the litigation industry
and the aiders and abettors that they've
developed in many courts across the
United States these developments and
these conditions are set forth
brilliantly in whalley olson's new book
the rule of lawyers which is your
centerpiece today literally and
figuratively he lays out in specific
detail the consequences of efforts by
plaintiffs lawyers and these judges to
usurp and commandeer the policy-making
processes which our constitutions
federal and state assigned to the
legislative branch
and I think that it's very important to
focus on that at a time when the
prospects for tort reform appear to be
particularly hopeful and to examine not
only in practical terms as I described
but in philosophic terms in terms of
what our frame of government is Wally
Olson offers as well some common-sense
ways to fine-tune our system to restore
balance to it and to deal with the
abuses that have developed he has more
than just a book like any
self-respecting author these days he has
a website and you can reach him at and
this is this is a classic I complement
you on this my friend his his email
address is overlord calm amen please
join me and listen carefully to Wally
Olson as he gives you a précis of his
important new book
that thank you so much for attorney
general Thornburgh it used to be in the
battle days that if you wanted to get
accurate news out of Russia that you had
to read Pravda but not as it was
intended to be read for example if an
article would appear they're saying that
the aviation ministry strenuously denies
that a civilian airliner recently
crashed near near Krasnoyarsk killing
126 civilians it was at that only at
that point that you could say AHA so
that's where it crashed and that's how
many people that there were and it is in
this spirit that i read the professional
legal press beam the the publications
like a lawyer is weekly and yes they do
publish some good things but in 1999 to
illustrate my point they published an
article about the aftermath of the
ground tobacco settlement which had
recently been announced and which was
bringing 246 billion dollars to the
coffers of the state governments and
some whirs upward of 10 billion dollars
in fees to the coffers of the nation's
plaintiffs lawyers and certain critics
had charged in their pettifogging way
that this was not going to be the end of
it that what happened to the de Roco
industry was going to be happening to
other industries to that the precedents
set in the tobacco litigation would soon
be turned against other types of
defendants and this was met with heated
denials at the tobacco industry we were
told was uniquely evil there was just no
one else who could be compared with it
attorneys I'm quoting lawyers weekly now
quote insist there is no list of
industries they are targeting trial
lawyers say big industry is trying to
scare the public shame on them into
thinking that a kind of cereal
litigation is underwear I love that
phrase serial litigation I used it for a
chapter title and it was at that point
that I realized it yes they're going to
do it it's now been officially denied so
we can deliver up
and and the Baltimore Sun soon reported
that quote before the ink was dry
unquote on the tobacco settlement that
lawyers in that city and elsewhere had
lined up a similar endeavor against the
companies that used to manufacture LED
pant 50 years ago and that they had
recruited state attorneys general and
and mayor's into that effort in October
1999 not long after the settlement the
newspapers were full of the suddenly
announced campaign against managed care
companies the public had kind of soured
on the techniques that managed care
companies used to contain medical costs
even though those techniques had been
specifically prescribed by Congress only
a few years before public opinion had
turned against it and there was
announced a series of massive lawsuits
which would try to get hundreds of
billions of dollars and would be run on
contingency by that leading tobacco
veteran lawyers the managed care
campaigns announcement destroyed 12
billion dollars of stock market value in
one day in managed care stocks and of
course there was the gun litigation
which had gotten underway slightly
before the tobacco settlement and in
which the gun manufacturers of America
that both the highly respected ones and
and the fly-by-night ones will all be
ensued demanding that they settle the
cases by agreeing to a long list of gun
controls which the US Congress had shown
no interest in passing therefore
documenting the need for immediate
passage of those gun control measures
well the problem with identifying the
next tobacco it soon turned out was that
there were too many candidates not too
few guns were the next tobacco we were
told so we're lead parent so was managed
care Microsoft according to the
Washington Post was the next Philip
Morris unquote gambling casinos
Hollywood for putting out violent
entertainment and of course as we
learned more recently the makers of food
which is too too fattening too tasty and
most insidious of all served to us in
portions that are too large
what about a week ago the new york times
around a kind of an offhanded piece by
one of its columnist saying sport
utility vehicles mark my word he said
they are next on the litigation agenda
how do we know this well they get into a
lot of accidents and they used to be
very popular so huge numbers were sold
but now they're getting unpopular and
the trial bar is very clever at
identifying things that are becoming
unpopular and getting out front with
litigation and I would not deny that
that he's right I think that probably
they are studying exactly thought as
another next tobacco now part of these
developments have a humdrum kind of
explanation which can be summarized in
the word reinvestment they were getting
these ten billion dollars in fees they
needed to go somewhere they couldn't buy
beachfront condos with all of them and
they needed to invest in the next rounds
of litigation but Dickie Scruggs for
example who was a leader of the managed
care litigation and and really the
mastermind in many people's view of the
tobacco litigation his firm was getting
what has been estimated at 1 billion
dollars it made the estimates may have
gone up or door down he needed something
to do with that he is among other
interesting things the brother-in-law of
former Senate Majority Leader Trent Lott
I am for some reason I never find that
people know that but he he announced it
not only did he organized the prime
moment of the managed care campaign in
which he visited Wall Street analysts
and told them that he could bankrupt the
company's thus helping the stocks to
fall thus increasing the pressure on the
defendants to settle but he also turned
up in the most remote sorts of places of
paper he was for example one of the
leaders in the crusade to turn civil
rights into another litigation another
personal injury caused by way of slavery
reparations suits go home and tell your
subfamily something they probably didn't
know which is the Trent lots
brother-in-law is a mastermind of the
slavery reparations litigation well that
so active was Dickie Scruggs and on so
many different fronts
that he got the appropriate reward which
was to be profiled in Time magazine and
i love how outspoken he was that's one
thing you have to give many of these 12
hours it he asked Scruggs if trial
lawyers are trying to run America and he
doesn't bother to do not deny it time
reported quote somebody's got to do it
well now something clearly had happened
here something had happened in in both
private life and in public life because
I could go on down through the through
other examples the in environmentalism
for example the new york times reported
that the sierra club and other leading
environmental groups haven't grown
frustrated at the prospect of getting
any sort of significant legislation
through the current climate in
washington what without president who
doesn't look to them for advice and to
congress that also doesn't that they
were going to try something new and
different have you guessed what it is it
is an alliance with project trial
warriors who cut their teeth in the
asbestos and tobacco litigation and they
announced that rather than continue to
petition the EPA to pass new regulations
the environmental protection agency to
pass new regulations that it is not
inclined to to pass they will sue
industry directly and then negotiate for
the same sorts of changes in the
emissions and pollution standards and
the flagship of this was the
announcement that they were suing
smithfield foods are the leading company
producing pork products for what they
said was the personal injury inflicted
by feedlots and pig facilities being
kind of dirty grimy unsightly smelly
places this was they calculated with
amazing specificity 148 billion dollars
a figure that must have been received
with some amazement in the Smithfield
executive offices because it was I think
more than 100 times the assets of the
company and the lawyers quickly
explained to the newspaper that they
didn't actually plan to go all the way
to trial get that
art and then find that they could only
collect 1% of it it was instead said the
tobacco lawyer veteran who talked to the
New York Times about it quote a
mechanism to bring industry to the table
a mechanism of terrorizing them into a
dotting stricter environmental controls
that then Washington said they had to so
something has happened with private
groups like the Sierra Club used to be
that they viewed the obvious thing to do
if the law was not strict enough as been
to work in Washington to pass HR 1805
that was a long tedious process you had
to make compromises you had to worry
about elections now there is something
that is much faster you dial 1 800
lawsuit you will be told by the lawyers
that you have to couch it as a giant
injury claim that's very important to
catch it not as what lawyers call an
injunctive matter where they simply
order future behavior no you have to as
with slavery reparations make it into a
huge dollar figure that you can ask
about for the past and that somehow or
other is where the contingency fee so
often seems to come in the lawyers will
pocket a portion of it and will they
ever work hard for you once you sign up
along them to pocket it for you they
will run a public campaign in which your
designated opponent is made to look
really really awful in the press and if
this works not only for private groups
like the Sierra Club but of course for
ambitious people within the government
itself state attorneys general about
mayor's who led the way or at least we
used as the front cause in most of the
significant runs of litigation within
the last year or two both San Francisco
and Philadelphia have set up within
their City Hall's what they call
affirmative litigation bureaus which are
meant to institutionalize permanently
the process of signing up with private
lawyers for campaigns to sue American
business this had a lot of implications
for legal professional one of them was
simply on the type of career path that
you could expect as a young lawyer it
used to be that you really had to choose
choose between two very different career
paths there was on the one hand personal
injury law yes there was tons of money
there
the other hand the prestige was loved
the politicians had very mixed feelings
about you yes you were their automatic
teller machine but they didn't want to
be seen that much in public with you and
you didn't get very good press rely on
the other hand there was public interest
law very very different area there you
got enormous amounts of prestige either
you worked for the government or else
you better yet you sued the government
demanding that they change their
policies that either way you had the
sense that you were doing something very
important in changing the law in helping
to shape the law that people lived under
and you often got terrific press out of
it but on the other hand there was not
nearly as much money it was a patch to
elbow kind of legal specialty this is of
course a relative matter you were still
a lawyer you still did enough to get
into the top two or three percent of the
income distribution but there would
probably not be landing strips in your
future that sort of thing and so you
used to have to you know pick one or the
other of the forks along this road and
now suddenly it was possible for people
to shape and rewrite the Y in
settlements while at the same time
collecting a percentage bounty for the
new tax they had imposed or the value of
the new regulations and this came to a
head of course in the tobacco litigation
were side by side working on the same
issues doing the same kind of legal work
were the state attorneys general own
civil service staff lawyers who were
making perhaps in the tens of thousands
of dollars per year and the hired
private contingency fee lawyers who
would help the state and who would often
send in bills in the tens of thousands
of dollars an hour instead of a year and
shortly after this an assistant attorney
general in the state of Washington
resigned in order to set up a
class-action private law firm explaining
when asked why he was quitting Steve
Berman got 50 million dollars and I got
a plaque
so so so suddenly there was a new legal
specialty which combined to the previous
legal specialties each of which was
pretty darn powerful and to the fans of
this new development of course not
nothing could be nicer I think it was
Katherine Hepburn who is credited with
the line about Astaire and Rogers that
well Fred gave ginger class and ginger
gave Fred sucks and that fit that was
their idea of how this work I mean you
got the prestige from the one side and
the money from the other side and the
power from both sides and and what could
be nicer especially since you could
change the world so much faster in a
more streamlined way than the tedious
old way of working for legislation those
old checks and balances had imposed an
awful lot of delay instead it now looked
as if you filed one of your massive
lawsuits and within months sometimes
within weeks there was the industry
quietly negotiating with you for some
sort of settlement you could get to a
settlement table with a great deal of
power on your hands in the gun
litigation for example Peter warrior of
the new yorker did a wonderful story on
the origins of the early gun litigation
on behalf of cities and he pointed out
quote as in the war against tobacco
winning in court isn't necessarily the
objective of the lawyers and he said if
twenty cities this was very early in the
litigation if twenty cities can be
recruited to sue the gun companies their
legal defense costs could be run up to 1
million dollars a day they soon had 30
cities instead of 20 quote said one of
the lawyers quote the legal fees alone
are enough to bankrupt the industry the
pressure is going to be on unquote and
there's a certain pride you know I would
I would apologize if I were going to
benefit from the sheer cost of imposing
legal fees but in this case it was a
matter of for Boston the wall street
journal reported in its news columns
around them that although gun companies
were already interested in settlement
they were being advised by some of the
private lawyers the cities were being
advised by some of the private lawyers
don't settle too early because they'll
they'll be nearer to running out of
money and the cities will be able to get
a better deal the closer
they are two going bankrupt well to me
this is not so much Fred and Ginger as a
way of combining two sources of powers
as maybe Bride of Frankenstein you you
have the unaccountability of strictly
private law the freedom of action that
private lawyers tend to both stand you
have the ability to dispose of
distinctively public questions that goes
along with government law and as I think
we could and should have predicted the
result of the new rounds of regulation
through litigation has been pretty much
a consistent disaster you have the
tobacco settlement and the Smith &
Wesson settlement abortive since it
seems to have collapsed but you have
those the first two examples to look out
in both cases you have settlements that
were reached behind closed doors the
great lack of transparency in the
process and you have settlements that in
which the negotiating parties manage to
solve their problems by loading enormous
burdens onto the backs of third parties
who were not as it turned out present in
the negotiating room in the tobacco
settlement they arranged to protect the
tobacco industry from competition while
raising prices of cigarettes a great
deal very bad news for smokers who were
paying a new tax but smokers did not
happen to be a party to the litigation I
in the Smith & Wesson case the burden
was born by dealers and by gun owners
once again no one was allowed to
intervene on their behalf the lack of
transparency is bad for a number of
reasons it is very bad if you think that
the public deserves some sort of direct
input in being able to lobby someone you
don't know who it is that we're supposed
to lobby if you are discontented with
the tobacco or gun settlements the
processes in both cases were kept from
almost any sort of public ability to get
at them and you also have the other
problem with lack of transparency which
is that people hire their friends
they're all law school roommates their
campaign contributors and in state after
state after state
having been an old law school friend of
your attorney general was suddenly the
ticket to becoming a sentient
millionaire the full scandal of the
tobacco fees the full extent to which
the attorneys general or around the
country not in every state but instance
in every region of the country succumbed
to the temptation of picking their
cronies their former colleagues they're
leading campaign contributors for a
series of contracts which were to prove
to be the most lucrative contracts
certainly in legal history arguably in
the history of government contracting at
all this is something that will put the
profession of attorney general of the
states not the federal Attorney General
under a cloud for I think for many
decades to come and the ultimate result
is to put enormous power in the hands of
a private elite which hides from public
scrutiny one of the stories that I fell
in my book is just how difficult it is
to document simple questions like how
much money did the lawyers get what were
the original retainers by which they got
themselves hired because when the press
began asking and in state after state
the the press did find this to be
interesting the lawyers would say no no
we're private lawyers we don't have to
disclose our retainers or the details of
our time sheets or the minutes of the
meetings at which they decided to hire
us yes they used Freedom of Information
requests when they were successful and
those were the results were quite
eye-opening even now even several years
later in Texas and elsewhere lawyers
have never been put under oath and have
never had to disclose exactly how it was
they came by the tobacco proceeds who
nonetheless even after that kind of
record you have a constituency out there
that likes this fed admires this is a
new form of governance and it is often
highly placed the mayor of Miami asked
why he was suing under Florida law when
the gun was at the state of Florida very
clearly do not countenance in fact that
nothing could be clearer to them in the
view of the Florida Legislature that
they were not
going to go along with the kind of gun
control that the mayor of Miami wanted
and he turned this around and he offered
this as the best excuse for filing suit
he quote said he was using the courts in
an attempt to crack down on the gun
industry because the florida legislature
had refused to do so every year that
i've come to the legislature we've
basically been told to take our case
elsewhere unquote which I translate is a
get lost please and the Clinton
administration which really really
should have known better I think
endorsed the gun litigation and
specifically the Smith & Wesson
settlement for having as been Europe
Tom's put it quote opened a new avenue
for regulating the firearms industry
without action from Congress said a
clinton administration official this
proves that the public good did not have
to be held hostage to legislative
stalemate legislative legislative
stalemate or legislative gridlock as the
times also called it is a euphemism for
we couldn't round up the votes no matter
how hard we look for them so we have a
right to sue instead it seems to me that
we stand now at a pivotal moment for a
couple of different reasons especially
because of the last election let me
preface this by saying that any sort of
reform however minor of this area has
proved to be almost impossible in the
past the first place you might look
would be to the legal profession itself
to engage in self-regulation as it once
did I trust you all on the verge of
laughter about that one I never made
anyone who takes seriously the potential
of the legal profession to regulate
itself you might think next the judges
could curb it by themselves and many of
them do try but the power of the lawyers
to simply select different judges if you
are being blocked in one set of course
you go off and file in Mississippi or
Alabama has thus far frustrated any
attempt to bring it under control
through a change in the judicial climate
and that mostly lives the same elected
branches of government that have stood
by in abdication as these powers have
been swept from them in recent years we
have just had a Republican sweep at the
federal level
this means we are told that there is
going to be a serious push for legal
reform and tort reform I think the White
House is sincere about wanting that to
happen I occasionally see some of the
private communications to the members of
the trial lawyers associations which are
slipped me by renegade trial lawyers and
they are quite confident that they will
have enough votes in the Senate to block
any filibuster the the 41 votes or
however many they need I would not count
on very much of significance happening
so long as 41 votes are all they need at
the same time there is the maximum
temptation for those who would like to
enlist in these undemocratic methods
because if you are the Sierra Club if
you are a civil rights activist who has
been trying to decide whether to spend
the next couple of years working on
reparations litigation efforts or
instead trying to pass some reforms
through legislation it must now be
maximally attempting to listen to the
trial lawyers given a Congress that is
not as well disposed so it is these
groups i think that are going to have
the most interest in internal debate at
precisely a liberal or left to use the
shorthand but but reformist groups who
don't feel that Washington is listening
sympathetic to them because they will
have to decide whether they believe more
in winning ground or in winning ground
democratically there is already
something of a debate on this Robert
Reich cabinet secretary under President
Clinton wrote a very eloquent piece
saying that he favored gun control he
favored structure control on tobacco but
please he said let's not win this way
let's win the way that we were taught we
should win in the democratic process I
hope he wins that debate because as I
see it and I hope you do too however
badly we as the people manage to do it
however slowly and however many mistakes
we make along the way we do deserve the
right to govern ourselves thanks
there are questions I see in the
audience let me preface the questions by
saying first could you identify yourself
as you asked and secondly could you take
a moment to let the gentleman from
c-span bring his microphone up because
otherwise we're not going to catch the
beginning of it for the television
audience yes Stanley goldstein thank you
all that was excellent particularly your
emphasis on the Sierra Club the
attorneys general as being part of a
coalition in the old days the judges
were we felt the bad guys because they
let these things go through we helped we
help to educate judges and you told us
how they with our problems go around
that how do we educate or persuade the
attorneys general who have all this
power now that this is hurting the
country I wish I had a good answer to
that part of it is that the culture of
attorneys general is kind of a subset of
the specialized culture of the legal
profession not that many people follow
them as a beach or in the press or
really know much about what they do
unless they're practicing lawyers in
which case you're likely to be on the
first name basis with your state's
attorney general if you're a powerful
warrior and so their incentives and
their feelings of what can be gotten
away with are shaped not by the voters
of this state I would argue but much
more about the legal culture within
their state even so the education has
been advancing one of the trends pointed
out by election analysts was that in the
last round or two of Elections attorneys
general have run for higher office often
governor or senator this is in itself is
nothing new the National Association of
attorneys general has long been
nicknamed the National Association of
aspiring governors what what one thing
that is kind of new is that they're
doing so badly out of the skip Humphrey
in Minnesota and Michael sir easy and
the same state who ran for senator and
at least a half dozen others around
who had thought that their success as
they saw it in the tobacco litigation
would make them very attractive
candidates found the voters cooler than
had been expected and I think that is
the beginning of signs that the public
in an inquiry not because it's figured
out all the things that went wrong but
because it knows from enough of the
surface stories about the money from the
tobacco settlement not being spent on
anti-smoking efforts but just to be
coming general revenues it senses that
it wasn't don't straight with and the
attorneys general who are if nothing
else for political quiz may figure out
that part of the equation in the back
yes New York Civic I don't have much
brief for the judges either and I'm a
great admirer of Ross Sandler and David
children who wrote this marvelous book
which I'm sure you know democracy by
decree about the judicial usurpation but
at the same time I'm not enthused about
Congress either because Congress is a
prisoner of the their political
contributions and their campaign
supporters and the lobbies that are
there every day so I hardly think that
Congress can be said to represent the
will of the people any more than the
judges do so while I agree with you
completely that these lawyers shouldn't
make a lot of money out of it I don't
know that the public policy results are
any worse than they would be if you
follow the Congressional pork barrel
guys yeah and as someone who has been
critical in my own way of a lot of the
things Congress has done I see your
point but I would say there are at least
two reactions that come to mind one of
them is that we are living under a
constitution in which the branches the
three original branches were designed
for specific purposes the founders
intended the judiciary to be less in
touch with public opinion than the other
two branches and I think the design
worked it is less in touch with public
and even then Congress and the executive
which can be pretty out of touch
sometimes set the arm you know the
judges get their their tenure or at
least they're very long terms and in the
states and their insulation from the
power to remove them from office and are
drawn from a much more elite class as a
group all because adjudication of
individual lawsuits may benefit from
that kind of elitism and not because the
reflection of the public will
necessarily benefits from it the second
point however which is is different is
that by insisting on thrusting on the
courts essentially democratic questions
of decision-making we wind up attraction
to the judiciary and ensuring that
confirmation fights and election fights
will wind up propelling toward the
judiciary those who treat the role as
basically being politicians by another
name or though those who don't mind
wielding legislative power and you see
this in the extraordinary ferocity of
the judicial confirmation battles and
the ferocity of the battles over locked
in state supreme courts both sides sense
that the courts now have so much power
to legislate their will into law that
are compromises on simply compromising
by identifying the technically most
qualified judges is no longer appealing
we want our guys in there we don't want
the people who are the most competent
warriors and that's really a shame and
that's not the way it should work with
the show sherry um yes judge would say
uh Thomas crew say I'm a judge in the
federal court here I realize you can't
cover every subject in your very fine
remarks but I still have to ask wasn't
there any merit under well-established
tort law to the claims in the asbestos
cases to tobacco cases and the other
cases you've talked about I guess the
answer to that has to be a case-by-case
one I do have a chapter on the asbestos
litigation I point out there that what
was going on is not what went on in the
breast implant who cares where the
science was more or less imaginary from
start to finish with asbestos there were
a lot of very gravely very genuinely
injured people and there were defendants
that had been intimately involved with
promoting asbestos now 20 years later of
course we have moved on to see a docket
dominated by people who are not actually
injured against companies that were not
actually in the asbestos business so you
know that what life moves on in in the
legal business we still call it as
bestest litigation but the problems
differ from area to area sometimes the
legal doctrines are relatively well
accepted but the science or the medical
charts are fanciful other times as in
the state tobacco litigation it's my
view and it's the view of I think many
beside myself that this was an
incredibly lame legal theory they wound
up putting it over by way of settlement
but there was precedent from the federal
courts which I see as being on point
precedent in which governments had
earlier tried to file recruitment
lawsuits saying that some businesses
negligence in cause him let's say a
train crash or an air crash inflicted
costs on the government of cleaning up
afterward you shouldn't we be reimbursed
for that the courts had said no sorry
even if it was negligence even if the
government wound up paying money because
of negligence there wasn't the privity
you don't have a right to see the
business for recovery the tobacco
litigation worked partly because of the
new model of running litigation is a
public campaign in which if you get
enough newspaper articles saying that
it's plausible some judges will go along
and partly because of the sheer pressure
that 50 states or 30 some states can
bring to bear by pushing a theory that
may not have much going for it in the
first place Michael Myers New York Civil
Rights Coalition I guess to paraphrase
of Shakespeare up until the revolution
there were there will be the rule of
lawyers
and and the plaintiffs bar within their
own defense would say we must be doing
something right because we're winning
we're winning McDonald's we were winning
hot coffee we're winning we're winning
everything and tobacco everything so
they must be doing something right but
isn't there stuff isn't a problem when
people are waiting in terms of with your
notion of democracy because you're not
only going to court you were standing
motions to dismiss your impaneling a
jury of people common average citizens
who bring in judgments and huge rigs and
awards which is a portion of the public
isn't a notion of cynicism in the public
if now when we're winning you begin to
change the rules in the middle of the
game and isn't there isn't the in the
notion of your scheme of democracy isn't
the court an equal part of our
governance construction so that when
cannot have a majority overwhelm or
overall the notion of individual rights
or you for that matter group rights in
terms of class action well I certainly
agree with part of what you say in that
in practice when they win they acquire
retroactive legitimacy the money changes
hands and it immediately appears too
much more of the public oh well there
must have been some legitimate legal
theory going on there if money changed
hands at the same time I think we part
company on some of the questions of how
they are winning you mentioned juries
for example and I've got a chapter in
there arguing that most of the
developments that people like me
complain about in the system most of the
outlandish verdict and extremely large
numbers are not emerging from juries
which are in any reasonable sense cross
sections of America there emerging from
particular jurisdictions where the
lawyers are allowed to run jury
selection in a manner that delightfully
crafted to give them highly
unrepresentative juries and those on
representative juries are then imposing
their will on often ten juries who have
voted otherwise in the same controversy
because you only need to win
small percentage of them in order to get
the momentum you need in following these
things in breast implants for example
after the conclusive studies that come
out refuting the scientific theories
most juries actually swung over to the
defense side and yet enough of them can
I only a minority of them but lawyers
continued to find juries here and there
who would vote five million dollars and
that was enough to keep the thing going
for years more so I wouldn't uh view the
situation as even as democratic as it
might appear on the surface what what is
going on with the motions to dismiss for
example is once again very much a
function of where the court is and who
the judge is the same action that would
be thrown out at a very early stage in
one state and by one judge down the hall
different judge in the same court and
the lawyers are very good you know there
are the techniques like following ten
suits seeing which judges are assigned
to them and then drop in at seven or
eight of the term in the back there if
you were to say that there is merit as
was just you could identify yourself to
save gorgeous I'm a judge in a Supreme
Court here in New York if there is in
fact merit to these lawsuits which if
there wasn't I guess it wouldn't be
these kinds of verdicts but if there was
a merit wouldn't you say the real issue
is the fact of the of the fees that are
being paid rather than throwing out the
baby with the water you're saying that
and there's checks and balances and by
the way we as judges are not here to do
the will of the people even though some
of the major changes like Brown versus
Board of Education really change a lot
of things and nothing occurred but it's
really the fees that I think that that
the people look toward as saying that
their excessive as opposed to the merit
of the case itself who is there going to
be to take care of the consumer who is
injured well and we agree as far as the
fears being a distinctive part of the
our reg and those of us who disagree on
many of the other substantive questions
I hope can agree that something needs to
be reexamined in a system that produces
such disproportionate is that having
been said your first to mark puzzled
male wittle because it was almost as if
you were saying that the success of the
climb was some sort of indicator that it
must have at least Hemi demi merit that
we know in the first place the great
majority of cases settled before verdict
and it's widely believed and I'm among
those who believe it that many of those
settlements are based not on an expert
calculation this case is going to go
against me as the defendant if it goes
to trial but other reasons why defendant
several cases that than that of those
that do go to trial and do prevail and
in the gunk liability case for example I
think it's widely seen that if the same
theory of gun maker liability for a
murder or a suicide is brought to juries
in 20 randomly selected towns and cities
around the country an awful lot of those
juries are going to return a defense
verdict because they believe that you
know the personal responsibility is what
should should govern here but there will
be a few places some big cities some
places that just are of an ideologically
different complexion where the juries
are not going to feel that we're we're
they're going to say yeah good you know
it's got these guns off the street and
who cares about the you know the
unwillingness of Washington dude to
change these things part of what I argue
is that even if it's only ten percent of
the juries that feel that second where
they're going to get set at the national
agenda because they're going to be able
to impose the liability on gun sales
everywhere that's what was going on in
the New York gun sale kiss it isn't
democratic it it would be one thing if
you could confine the results of a
Brooklyn jury to Brooklyn alone but
instead Brooklyn ones up making a
nationwide policy should it
I know where judge Perkins court sets
over here if a fee I'd how far away is
I'm sorry that uh why don't we do a
question over there and then we'll get
over to you out afterward commended for
your book because it lays out so
thoroughly an enormous problem where
we've got the rule of law we've got
checks and balances we've got so much of
the heart of our legal system on the
line the problem we have is what can we
do about it and I think that it is such
a multi-faceted problem and it's so
widespread and so deep that it's going
to take a lot of different remedial
initiatives in my judgment to get this
thing under control and I think one of
the things that we need to think about
is well how do we get some leadership
this is going to be tough and it's going
to be very expensive and it could be
politically very dangerous and difficult
but the stakes are so high you have to
hope that somewhere the leadership can
evolve I think within the business
community it's been in fits and starts
but it has to be an important part but
it certainly can't do it alone but
somewhere there has to be a remedial
proposal that would address such a
substantial part of it that the prize
might have a chance of rallying enough
critical mass of resources to go after
this my own personal judgment is that
you've got to get into this whole area
of class action and this partnership
between the state attorney general's and
the trial lawyers that create a
situation where few plaintiffs will ever
go to trial it's just a gun at the head
and they have to pay but i'd be
interested in any comments that you
might have on some of the points that
i've just raised well thanks that was
built up by the way who is retired on
for purposes of audience identification
I I have a section on reforms in the
book although I did not put it in my
remarks here and I tried to come up with
something a little bit new because I
have been recommending certain types of
reforms which have been very handily
blocked by the powers that be when they
proposed in the past and my argument
proceeds it follows the new litigation
elite as i call it is at one in the same
time an incredibly successful private
industry and also in its own view a
fourth branch of government and let's
take them seriously on both of those
phenomenon let us treat them as an
industry in imposing on them at least as
much consumer protection regulation as
all their industries as banking or as
insurance for example would be subjected
to since there are lot of supporters of
regulation in the consumer interest for
the most part they should welcome a
regime of least favorite regular tea if
you want to call it that in which the
principles that apply to rate control
and control of private contracts by
credit card companies and walk should
all be applied to lawyers retainers
that's number one it would do a lot for
fees I think to come up with a consumer
protection regimen through the Federal
Trade Commission which I'm happy to say
by coincidence is in fact developing a
consumer protection regimen for lawyers
secondly and in quite in contrast to
that let us take them for the moment
seriously in the claim to be a fourth
branch of government and let us bring to
them the kinds of controls in terms of
living in a fishbowl massive disclosures
of financial conflicts that the other
three branches have to put up with all
and it would gain us so much territory
in reforming the legal profession if
there were just more disclosure or I
think the disclosure remedies would be
enough to occupy us for years and would
naturally and inevitably lead to more
reforms because once we finally get a
good look at how they do their business
we will not only have a much better idea
of what comes next for reform but the
public will beam in my view much more
outraged to finally nail down what it is
they've done so that is my
recommendation is come up with mandatory
disclosures for lawyers whose work is
charged with the public interest if it
is charged with a public interest and
they shouldn't mind disclosing a whole
lot more than they currently do about
how they get hired how they
settle their kisses and how much they
make from it question over here I think
my name is Jean Harper I was going to
follow up on Henry Stearns question but
the gentlemen have just asked the
question pretty much asked the same
asked the same thing there are costs
here and as a matter of public policy we
want to reduce the costs and the
transaction costs of reducing the costs
I take it and it's very rare as the
Manhattan Institute to hear somebody
talk about government regulation as a
way of doing that but many of the costs
are costs incurred by non-parties to the
transactions people who don't smoke okay
and the question is how do we reduce the
sum of the costs the costs that are
imposed in the transaction costs of
reducing them other than having trial
lawyers disclose how much money they
make and why is that your bottom line
that that will serve to reduce the sum
of the costs in these areas if we get
trial lawyers to disclose their be as I
handed out a moment ago I have other
reform ideas some of which I've laid out
in the litigation explosion published in
1991 I came to settle on disclosure as
an overarching reform in part because
it's so hard to make the case for more
ambitious things until you can pin down
and satisfy observers in the press and
in academia as to the scope of the
problem of the prevalence of abuse all
the things that are hard to document so
long as they can keep it all off the
public record and that's why there's the
long discussion of disclosure in my new
book the rule of lawyers at the same
time I don't apologize for the paradox
of liking regulation in this area
because to me what's going on here is a
classically governmental process it is
not in fact private enterprise it is all
variations of Forestry distribution
and although i'm not one of those who
says that all lawyers should consider
themselves is working for the government
or working for the courts nonetheless
the old idea of there being an officer
of the court and if they're having an
ethical obligation to take into account
something other than winning for their
clients there was something real behind
that something that reflected the fact
that the power that lawyers have to go
to court and drag people into incredibly
expensive litigation is a power
graduated them as a kind of delegation
of government power so we have you know
that fat is kind of a basis a minimum
for reform there are plenty of other
good ideas that I've said nothing about
there's one right behind you know you
know my name is Norman rip I'm a just
retired judge of the civil in the
Supreme Court for 28 years i sat in
Manhattan and like judge gorgeous i
presided over thousands of trials
including ninety-five percent of the
cases that were settled I think when you
speak about the elite lawyers you seem
to only categorize the plaintiffs
lawyers but there are defense lawyers
and they want to work trying cases or
settling cases as well so I think you
have to include them as well they work
on per diem they don't work on
contingencies but they are a significant
element as to whether a case is settled
because the client says the insurer says
well what do you think you think we can
win this if the defendants think they
can win it they're going to go to win it
the cases mostly our settle is because
the defendants feel that they may not
win and they want to buy it wholesale
now the only exception I think to which
you allude is where you have a
nationwide industry and or a global
industry which is more subject to the
media and that's what impacts and you're
right I think judge Burgess is right
there has to be some regulation on the
huge contingent fees where the lawyers
make more than a client who makes
sometimes a pittance but there has to be
full disclosure of fees and costs by the
defense as well as the plaintiffs
lawyers yeah you you raise it very
interesting point here and I don't
forget that then but both points you
raise first on the media I couldn't
agree more that it is the prospect of
publicity and that is often the key
hammer in getting defendants to settle
cases that they think are lousy on the
law or on the facts and virtually
everything I talked about in this book
is on the category of litigation that
gets into the newspapers that is done as
a public campaign there's a chapter
specifically on lawyers relations with
the media and unpublicized cases do have
a different dynamic and probably a less
abusive dynamic as a result at the same
time I've got some darts in there
against defense lawyers because their
interests are not always well aligned
with those of their clients in
particular I was amazed to find that in
case after case were litigation reform
was proposed which was unambiguously
good for defendants portions of the
defense bar and sometimes the leading
portions of the defense bar were quietly
opposing those reforms sometimes they
were on matters like we do sin the cost
of pretrial discovery something where
both sides could potentially get trial
faster with lower overhead and only the
lawyers would lose fees well isn't it
funny both the plaintiffs in the defense
bar quietly managed to talk about those
things there is a real responsibility
there at in the defense bar often
they've too often they've fallen flat on
their face and have not lived up to the
responsibilities lawyers at the
initiative says judge you know in
private I'll settle this case but I
can't settle it today I'll settle it
next Monday now he didn't say why but
the understanding was I have to make my
per diem so it takes two to tango
what one more question John Stossel I'm
sorry about the microphone being so far
away is it it's john stossel ABC News
here comes microphone read this book and
it is excellent and infuriating which
makes me surprised at some of the
comments from the judges here who seemed
to accept this system where politicians
are giving not thousands of dollars but
hundreds of millions of dollars to their
cronies companies are being bankrupt is
in the breast implant cases where the
science wasn't there why isn't there
more outrage and in my profession
there's it's not on the hundred millions
of dollars being confiscated it's not on
the front pages why do you think that is
well you've you asked me to read their
minds I think part of it is that you've
read the book I that they only have my
remarks to go on and they think of the
cases and you know it remains a fact of
life that most cases are not going to be
extraordinarily abusive like looking
like whoa bukannya that they can't all
be worse than average and babe and I
write about ones which are unusually
abusive but also ones i think that are
unusually big and expensive and it does
a system no good if the majority of
cases are not abusive but they're the
small cases thanks very much for turning
up